[Music]
plenty of female talent by the way to
talk about on the new Forbes list of top
earning actresses starting with one
enchanting oscar nominee amy adams
arrived at number 10 her oscar-nominated
alien thriller helped her make over 11
million dollars in the past year we
ranked our highest-paid actresses lists
by looking at upfront fees and back-end
profits for movies as well as
endorsement paychecks Cate Blanchett and
Julia Roberts are next on the list Julia
Roberts may only had one movie in
theaters this year that Smurfs film
don't be weird but thanks to
endorsements and residuals from older
films she still makes the cut next Emma
Watson who tied with Charlize Theron is
a newcomer to the top ten
she earned 14 million dollars thanks in
large part to Beauty and the Beast this
was a huge deal for me
Mila Kunis kicks off the top 5 with 15
point five million dollars proving it's
good to be a bad mom Melissa McCarthy
laughed her way to the number 4 spot her
comedies helped her earn 18 million
dollars while Jennifer Lawrence fell
from the top spot to number 3 without a
Hunger Games movie she only made 24
million dollars that's down from 46
million last year
another Jen Jen Aniston is right above
JLo some might be surprised to see
Jennifer Aniston and number 2 on this
year's list but she still makes millions
from endorsements for SmartWater
interview
and dancing into the top spot for the
first time oscar-winner and the stone
juror earnings are up from ten million
last year to twenty-six million this
year thanks to our paychecks from Long
Island I got a call back
what come on
you